thank you andy
so my name is steve cousins i'm a
graduate of stanford i was here
20 years ago i was remembering that i
had
somewhere i couldn't find it i would
have brought a picture of my son riding
on one of the stanford robots when he
was 18 months old
he's now 23 so i'm giving away a little
bit about my age
and things have changed a lot in those
20 years so if i can
describe um what it was like here in
ila norbosh if you know him who's been a
stanford he's been a cmu professor for
the last
two decades maybe since he left here he
was my ta in this class
and what we had was a robot that had
a ring of sonars around it a ring of ir
sensors around it
so 16 16 numbers right
and our goal was we were still in
margaret jacks at the time to drive from
one
intersection in a corridor to another
right so just
you have a map of the it's a very simple
map it's basically a connected graph
you want to get from point a to point b
and try not to get lost
it was enormously hard work it took us
all semester to get it to do that
we were using macbooks or whatever the
original apple laptop was
powered on top of that robot and
we were most of the time able to get it
to go to that spot and we said
like wouldn't it be cool if we could get
it to go like across
campus or something this was the big
thing um it was really hard
uh and and i asked this question like
what would you even if you solved this
what would you use it for
right and now i find myself 20 years
later building a robot that's very
similar to that
we solved that problem and i think we
found a use for it so that's
kind of what i'm going to talk about the
other story i'll tell just briefly about
my long ago histories um how i my first
robot that i encountered and i'll these
were robot in quotes there
i had a robot that or my sister got a
robot for
she was hit by a car she was okay but
she was in hospital and when she came
out somebody gave her this amazing
hundred dollar toy
in those days was a lot of money she was
two years old so that was like
almost 50 years ago and it was a remote
control doll
it was the coolest thing and i realized
that what's cool about robots is we can
make them do action at a distance we can
impose our will on them we can ask them
to do things for us
we can control them and that was the
beginning of that that was
even though it was a wired remote and
you know 10 years later i wouldn't have
wanted that as a toy
for myself when i was really little that
was that was really cool
um so i'm going to talk broadly about
lots of different kinds of robots and
try to ask some questions about
how do you distinguish them because one
of the things that's really hard about
robotics is
answering the question what's a robot so
you say what you say a robot is
something with sensors and actuators and
processing
and then somebody asks well isn't that a
microwave yeah that's a microwave
that's not a robot and so you get into
this whole debate it's kind of like the
questions with ai
you know if you can define it it's no
longer ai or if you understand it it's
no longer ai
so this is kind of a list that i've been
playing with 10 ways to compare robots
i think there's still 10. maybe there's
9 now
anyway moving moving versus fix so you
think about a robot arm
and you think about a mobile robot
they're different and there's mobile
manipulators but they're kind of rare
light versus heavy weak versus strong
indoor versus outdoor you can segment
the classes of robots very strongly
along that line
scripted versus unscripted there's a lot
of robots that just follow a path just
do the same thing over and over
flying versus grounded there's all these
drones now
teleapp versus autonomous uncontrolled
versus a structured environment so
that's what
andy was just talking about where robots
for 50 years have been working very
productively behind
fences in in construction environments
and now they're coming out
and finally a really important one in
robotics is demo versus deployment so
when i got back into robotics about
seven years ago
at willow garage we looked around and
realized that
in the robotics community usually the
coin of the realm was videos so you
would go to a conference and say here's
my video and they'd say here's my video
my video is cooler than your video
and could i see your robot actually do
that oh no no it only worked when i
you know i took a lot of video that's
the one you get to see
right um and and things have changed a
lot over that years and one of the
things that we did over
um the six years that i spent at willow
garage was focused on building
a robust robot the pr2 that came out of
stanford robotics lab
um and making it available to lots of
robotics labs and then building the
robot operating system on top of that
um also work that started here um
and getting that out so that it's now
sort of the
de facto standard in robotics and i'll
show a little bit of that
this is not going to be a super
technical talk but again a kind of a
broad
a broad talk so research and education
is one place that robots start and
and i mentioned two here um these are
the two
that are sort of easiest to buy right so
there's a lot of
robots and i'll show you a video with a
lot of different research robots
and you all know what they look like
there's a lot of 80 20 involved a lot of
wires that you can visibly see
um these are two robots that are
designed and there's
there's others but these are two robots
that were designed to be mobile
robots with arms for research okay
and the pr2 is the one that again the
pr1 came out of stanford and the um
out of ken salisbury's lab and the pr2
was the kind of follow-on generation
that
i think there's 50 of them in the world
now at all kinds of places they're here
they're at
mit berkeley stanford
penn georgia tech all kinds of places
so this is the pr2 in action and this is
a video that's probably about four years
old now
showing um at the time sort of
visualization how it was building a map
um you can see uh sort of navigation one
of the fundamental rules of robot
navigation is just don't hit anything
don't hit anybody
and willow garage there were dents in
the walls but they were from teleop
not the very rare that the robot would
hit something while driving itself
you can see there's a lot of
visualization tools that the tour de
force for the pr2 in the early days we
called it milestone two
after we got the robot navigating was
getting it to plug itself in
and this is not the right way to charge
a robot right you should build a dock
that's the engineering solution but if
you want to prove that the arms can do a
very precise task
this is kind of a cool thing to do so
that was the
kind of the beginning of pr2 when we had
a working prototype
peter abel's group at berkeley got the
robot to fold towels
and this is the kind of how they did it
you you get the robot to pick it up by a
corner
and then eventually do this if you want
to get a lot of hits on youtube which
this
video did what you do is this move right
coming up here
you just go like this and like
wow that's cool it must be human it
knows to get the things out
um so this was a this was a pretty cool
thing this robot took
one of the reporters who reported on it
said it could do 25 towels a minute that
was inverted it did one towel every 25
minutes
it's a pretty important difference and
um
and peter's i think gotten that down to
under four minutes per towel
which is you know a huge improvement
compared to 25
but still not taking anybody who folds
towels for a living out of work
um and then this was another tour de
force
at willow garage we once we had the
robot once we had the first version of
the robot operating system
we said can we make it do the thing that
all graduate students want which is to
get a beer from and take it out of the
fridge and bring it to me
they made a little web interface you
told it what kind of beer you wanted if
you pick a guinness
if you on the screen it will pick out
the guinness if you pick bud light
it pops up a dialog box are you sure you
want bud light
so it's a very smart robot and and then
it
uses the navigation technique they
actually added a little cup holder there
and the cool thing about this this was a
one week project
one week eight engineers right so take
the underlying platform and say
go do this we did another project um
which i won't show the video right now
but it was called pool shark and you can
see it on youtube and pool shark was
another one week hackathon
get the robot to play pool in a week
and they used an open source pool
physics simulator to do that
um so pretty cool this one um
they use they got coors light or corona
i guess
um corona is okay um and they made a
mess
so anyway this was that was that was
kind of a cool thing there
so so this is all built on software
called the robot operating system and
you'll see
um a bunch of this was a weekend project
get the robot to read midi files and
play at university of pennsylvania
and you see just a lot of different
robots here these are
kuka arms on top of obviously homemade
base these are
early drones at the university of
pennsylvania doing some cool things
inside of a motion capture system so
that they could get position
this is here at stanford morgan
quigley's building a robot arm
this is that now robot i mentioned
earlier but using ross to navigate
dancing with the robot out of germany
called the kerabot this is out of zurich
uh robots that go through pipes what's
interesting and what's common about all
this is our autonomous car
all of these robots are running ross
or some parts of ross and i say some
parts of ross because this is obviously
not exactly your typical robot
they're using an accelerometer on the
board and using all the ross tools to
visualize it in 3d
this is a turtlebot sort of the lowest
cost ross
robot that we built at the time this is
lego mindstorms but you had to run the
ross on a separate computer not on board
and this is a robot at georgia tech so
you get the idea there's a lot of
research
robots they look a lot different and
what's cool is that this robot operating
system
works on a lot of them
so what this means in terms of
you know the point today is that robots
are
coming online and becoming available
commercially
for the first time around people and
it's not that there haven't been any but
there haven't been very many
um and i think that's due to technical
enablers
ross free software that lets you get
started so we're um
savio fast forward a little bit saviok
is
now 16 people we started at seven people
we've been in business for 15 months
we've got
a robot on the in the field and two more
that's we built hardware we had software
we got the thing working
in a year right we were in ten months
the first deployment
that's incredibly fast and that's due to
ross right that's due to the fact that
we can start with a working code base
and improve the parts that need to be
improved it's also due
and robots coming down in price is
another reason that they're going to be
available the pr2 would be cool you
could you could have it deliver beers in
restaurants it'd be awesome
at 280 000 a pop it takes a lot of
creativity
to justify how you're going to make
money at that in a restaurant
and then cheap sensors is a big deal we
built the pr2 we put
um a stereo head
and a structured light sort of projector
that that
put out a light pattern so you could
actually do essentially what the connect
does but we built that custom that was
probably a
four thousand five thousand dollar bomb
part of the robot
very expensive um the connect came out
for 150 dollars
right and they sold millions and
millions of them um that's the good news
the bad news is apple bought
prime sense which makes the connect and
so they're not as easy to find now but
um but the technology is coming to the
point where it's now consumer products
right and
one of the things i sometimes say is
that robotics is the poor stepchild of
every other industry
right every other industry has volume
and today robotics really doesn't have
much volume with the
probably notable exception of irobot
who's got
a lot of roombas in the world i think 10
or 12 million
um this is the probably the best thing
that came out of
will garage in terms of the robot so
people ask all the time what's this
robot for and this is a man named henry
evans
who called us up and said i saw your
robot on cnn
and i think it could be my external body
henry was a cfo of a silicon valley
company had a brain stem stroke
about 11 years ago now um and
he just called us he types using his
head um on a keyboard
or he can use that board that he uses to
speak to his wife uh but here's the clip
that he saw on cnn and he said
hey can i get access to one of those and
so we started this project called robots
for humanity
and this is the interface that was built
he actually used
powerpoint to draw an interface so this
is what this is how i want to work it
and then sent us that we sent it to a
georgia tech grad student who built the
interface to control the robot and then
henry went
and used it first thing he did with the
robot was
turn it on himself as you can see here
and this was actually this is a
recreation the first time he didn't have
anything in the robot's hand he put the
hand right in front of his face and
we're like holding the run stop what's
he gonna do
and he scratched an itch on his nose
right it's like
it was the most touching moment then he
said what we said what else do you want
to do with the robot he said i want to
shave myself
and so we actually you can see here
there's a force torque sensor attached
to the kind of a razor head
that four stroke sensor tells you how
hard he's pushing and so we had his wife
shave him the way she normally does and
he shaved himself
he pushes 10 times harder right so
so no wonder he wanted to shave himself
right but it's also just about his
dignity and being able to do things for
himself
so um this is him using the robot on a
at a
from a distance so he's in one room he's
cannot see the robot now his eyes off
um he's in another room the robot's
opening a drawer he's watching it he's
watching through video feeds
and he's using it as essentially a
remote body
and later we took this robot to his
house he drove it
across his home opened a drawer took out
a towel brought it back and used it to
wipe his face
right so imagine for somebody who's mute
and quadriplegic who can't
basically do anything with the world
except for move his head around
suddenly he's able to affect things
there was a clip just there of him
handing out
um candy to trick-or-treaters we did a
thing here at stanford shopping center
um so this is this is a project that as
you can tell i'm passionate about
and and and drives me one of the first
things we did when we started savvy oak
as we were exploring what was our
project going to be
we funded a project at the university of
pennsylvania
and they built this robot called
scratchbot
well they didn't call it scratch but
henry calls it scratchbot so i use that
name
here's it's this is a carbon fiber uh
robot arm
very lightweight counterbalanced
designed to be
you know something that's not going to
kill him while we're not looking
it's an important feature um and he uses
it basically to scratch his itch and
it's
mounted to his table as you can see this
is his bed at home and he uses it
basically every day
um he estimates he gets an itch um
20 times an hour something like that so
you can imagine how long you can wait
before you just want to scratch and he
has
you know some signal with his eyes that
he uses for his wife to scratch
but it's uh you know it's not favorite
thing to have to ask for that it's much
happier doing it himself
and you can see he really goes at it
he's a very funny guy he has a
ted talk where he talks about his
disability if you're if you're
interested
and he made a point to say on the ted
talk that he routinely beats his friend
steve cousins at work with friends so i
i really appreciated that
um henry thanks um
uh so let me step back and talk about
other robots now um what are the most
prevalent robots in the world there's 10
there used to be 10 million roombas i
think there's more like 12 million
irobot roombas and then there's a lot of
knockoff
vacuum cleaning robots it's a pretty
good idea right so there's a lot of
vacuum cleaners in the world they have a
characteristic that almost all of them
are or the roomba in particular is
random right sort of doing a random walk
it's got some algorithms inside to make
sure that it's going to get covered
statistically over time
it doesn't make nice neat rows
competitors like the neato
vacuum out of from around here
can go in nice neat rows i'm using some
some cool technology low-cost lasers
i don't know if they've sold quite as
well but
but there's there's a lot of vacuum
cleaning robots that's the only
besides pool sweeps i guess that's the
only real home robot that's taken off
right and i we did a study at willow we
asked people what do you want in a home
robot
and they were very clear you know i
wanted to do my laundry
i wanted to do the dishes i wanted to do
my homework
right so so the third one you can see
why that may not be a good idea
um you could just excuse the homework
that would be easier
a lot easier you could grade the
homework um
the second one uh doing the dishes
you have a dishwasher right and so
there's something that you want but it's
not
just doing the dishes what you really
want is someone to like clean up the
kitchen
beside the dishwashing part right or you
want somebody to do the pots
pot scrubber or something like that the
laundry you have a washer and a dryer so
it's not that you want it to you know
stop you from having to go down to the
rock by the river
that's not the point the point is i
wanted to take my
dirty clothes from the hamper put them
into the washer move it into the dryer
take it out of the dryer fold them and
put them away that's the rest of the
laundry task
those are really really hard tasks for a
robot pr2 we tried to have the robot
just empty the
dishwasher empty the dishwasher it's a
simple task
and you have to you have to have a
certain sense of feel if you grab a dish
like a plate in a dishwasher and you
pull up on it
what happens the rack comes right you
automatically move it wiggle it if you
don't wiggle it
it's not coming out right and so there's
a pretty complicated
manipulation that's required just to do
simple empty in the dishwasher
and you've got to be pretty strong right
and you've got to have a pretty good
reach the pr2 was designed it's got
it's like about this tall right it's
designed to go taller and shorter
shorter so that it could reach the
ground it's got these kind of gorilla
arms
and still it can't because it because it
doesn't have a waist
right it's only got its arms it's like
you try to put your dishes away while
you stand straight up or if you have a
back problem it's going to be really
hard to reach that cabinet
right so it turns out home robotics is
really hard
on the other side factories there's only
about 2 million factory robots they're
incredibly productive right you don't
really want to drive in a car that
wasn't built with a welding robot
because they're very they don't miss any
welds right everything gets done where
you want
they weren't made on monday morning if
you can imagine that scenario
and so factory robots have been really
really popular and they've been behind
fences
telepresence robots are really popular
and i'll tell you a quick story about
um at willow we built a telepresence
robot called the tex eye
it was named that because there was a
guy named dallas who lived in
indiana he was a great engineer and we
wanted to hire him and dallas
uh um got frustrated with
sort of the polycom in the middle of the
table and so he said can i get a laptop
and skype and so we got him a laptop
and skype and put it at the end of the
table and then he complained that he
couldn't see the screen very well with
the little camera
could we get him a better camera and
could we get him a camera that he could
turn around
and we kept on making it better to try
to you know bring him more into the
picture
all this time i wasn't in those meetings
this was kind of the double e team
meetings at willow
so i barely know this guy all i know is
as a ceo of willow i have to pay taxes
in indiana
right so i end up so i know he exists
but but otherwise i don't know him very
well
suddenly they come on this plan where
they've they've now evolved this laptop
into a
desktop computer with a big screen with
a nice camera that can move around
and they put it on a cart with an
unrippable power supply so that they can
push it into the lab without turning it
off and then they went wait a minute
we're a robotics company right we can do
better than this and they
took the caster from the pr2 we had done
a rev on the casters to make them
quieter they took a noisy caster and
they attached it to the bottom of this
frame
and suddenly dallas with a joystick can
drive down the hall in this kind of
contraption
it was totally life-altering right
because suddenly
um i would walk down the hall and
there's dallas rolling down the hall
right with his face on the screen i go
hey dallas and go hey steve and we just
passed right it's like
ah you you start to know that this
person exists you know he could come to
lunch
he couldn't eat but he could come to
lunch and at least converse with people
so that robot became the tech side and
it became the suitable beam so if you
know the beam
dallas is working for suitable scott
hassan who funded
founded and funded willow is now running
suitable um
and and they produced this thing called
the beam which is this middle robot here
um there's a lot of robots in this
telepresence space
um eric schmidt once explained to me why
telepresence was so important to him
he said you know i have all the travel
amenities known to man i have my own jet
i can fly my own jet um i can go first
class i can
stay in the nicest hotels but travel's
still killing me but with something like
this i can avoid the trip
and that's a big deal right now we're
not all eric schmidt but
it is very nice to be able to set up
work groups where you have remote
participants this way
and at willow we had four beams and
people working all around the world and
it it does work
if you come into uh you know if you have
a meeting this this room's okay because
we have this
um side but if you have a way for the
beam to come in you get into the next
generation of problems which is like
where should i park the beam if you it's
nice to be in the front row but then
nobody behind you can see things like
that
the other ones here the irobot
ava is a they're working with in-touch
health so they're using these in
hospitals as a robodoc
and there are apparently some hospitals
that are robo doc only at night
so there's um you know you can get a
specialist but you're gonna you're not
gonna get the
like the only kid you if you're in a
remote hospital you're not gonna get the
only kid
in that specialty who would it was like
the last job you could get
right you're going to get the best
person from wherever
calling in because they can do that and
they can moonlight or maybe they're even
daytime for them
and double is in the space double is
interesting because it's self-balancing
one so that's kind of interesting and
scary um
and and also it's very cheap it's on two
thousand dollars so that was
um that was a really interesting price
point and they've done very well
another class of robots i'm talking
about kind of as robots are moving into
the service industry and there's this
another
class called kiosks i'm calling them
kiosk bots i don't think they call
themselves that
um but maybe it'll catch on and one of
them is called pepper
pepper is a um it's a robot out of
uh actually out of france so there's a
company called aldebaran and i'll show
you
well i showed you the now earlier
unfortunately i have a clip for this but
i have to be on the network and i'm not
so
but you can look up pepper on youtube
and see a video of it
what's interesting about pepper is that
it moves very gracefully
it doesn't it's got hands but it doesn't
really hold anything it's not designed
to pick things up and manipulate them
it's designed to be a kiosk right sort
of stand there and greet you when you
come into a into a store
ash the orchard supply hardware which is
part of lowe's has introduced the oshbot
which is similar um it's got a tablet on
the front and a tablet on the back
so you can so it can advertise all the
time no matter which way you're facing i
guess
and you can interact with it and and
they're working on various
ai techniques to let you do interaction
and find things in the store
which one
the pepper or the it's i think it's like
this big
um i actually haven't seen one in person
yet um i know that now is like
on the stands on the desk it's about
this tall and then the peppers like this
and then they're building one that's
bigger
um so there um
alder brown is run by a guy named bruno
masoniere and bruno is very big into
um humanoid robots and believes that
robots should
should be social and there's there's a
definitely a
school of thought and i think it's not
universal but there's a school of
thought that
making robots more social making them
more humanoid
is a good thing in some way and there's
also school of thought which is closer
to where i am which is that
you make robots useful and if you make
them too close to humans it gets
kind of freaky and um and so i think you
know there's going to be
uh time will tell which ones are more
popular which ones get
um get adopted i can tell you that
you know the cost of the robot goes with
the number of degrees of freedom number
of motors and so if you go with a robot
that's simple you
save some money and then there's this
category of
delivery bots the delivery bots have
been around in small quantities and
hospitals
for about 10 years now maybe 12 years
now
and uh the athon tug um
on the left here is uh sort of the
classic there and then a company called
vekna announced one
three or four years ago we've built and
i'll show you more about it the savvy
one
which is a a robot that's designed to be
smaller basically more nimble smaller
loads and really operate around people
where some of the bigger robots if they
do ride an elevator in a big building
insist on going in uh by themselves so
basically i'm not going to get in unless
it's empty or i'm going to clear out the
car
sort of satisfy all the car calls before
i get in we just
get in the car with people if there's
space right and and take advantage of
the fact that the robot's around so that
it can spin in place
and face the door
so i'm going to dive in a little bit and
talk about
savvy one also known as the butler we're
working with starwood and we've actually
had since august have had a robot in the
field it's done about
1400 deliveries um 400 of those
actual to guests and another thousand
kind of test runs up and down the
elevator
and about um we just crossed last week
100 miles
of indoor travel so it's it's coming
along the first one and we're about to
go into two more hotels so it's a
pretty exciting time and kind of is
growing but this is kind of where it
came from and again this is where we
started
i think this picture was shot
sometime early this summer like around
may probably
and what you see is a whole bunch of
robots that look like
junk right foam core little frames
that's how we prototype so we
we built a prototype with that was
basically a roomba or irobot create
with some sensors on it said can we get
the basics off we're turning over here
just put some processor
we built a bigger one we put a foam core
that's about the height that we want it
to be
we mount the sensors up high let's test
that one
we built this frame the frame is cool so
you take a piece of mdf 4x4
take it to a laser cutting shop with the
right pattern they give you a bunch of
pieces back you glue them together
you have a frame you put it on top of a
base um
we had this problem of well we want to
try this thing out in the field as soon
as possible how are we going to
dress it up and so i suggested spandex
um
and we tried it and adrian conoso is a
sport and our industrial designer and he
he wrapped it in spandex and took the
picture and then he ripped it off
so we got rid of the spandex and did
this now this is interesting how do you
make
this nice plastic cover in quantity one
for not too much money in a startup
budget this was before we had our seed
mutton
and the answer is you get a 3d printer
and you print lots of little pieces
but you've designed them with cad so
that they all glue together and go on
the frame
and then we learned another cool trick
which is you take that
robot that you've built and then you
give it to an auto body finisher
and they and they make it look really
pretty so it's a pretty
pretty nice prototyping technique that
we use to get the first version
working so this is what came out of it
oops
this is a video that a loft made
starwood made for us
it's a little bit rock music-ish i guess
it's actually not that different from
the experience at the aloft it's
actually like fluorescent lights in the
elevator it's kind of a weird place
um but the robot in a nutshell
you call the front desk you say i want a
water could you send me up a sandwich
and they basically charge it to your
room put it in the robot
type in your room number and the robot
shows up at your door calls your room
you answer the phone and open the door
and then there's a very cool locking
mechanism when the um
the robot's lid is locked uh when it's
sitting there and then when you
open your door it sees the door open so
that it opens its lid right so then you
get it safely and securely without
having to do a pin code or
or some biometrics or whatever so this
is the this is the savvy one it's here
um and i'll just give you a very quick
demo
so as i said somebody imagine i'm the
front desk agent somebody calls me up
uh the robot's sitting here in its dock
saying hello i'm ready to deliver
so i have to enter a passcode um
and then i have to enter a room number
and i think i put room 100
in this room room 100 is simulated it's
over there
and so then i say load so passcode is to
keep the nine year olds from sending it
around the hotel if they get a hold of
it
and the room number is sort of the
minimal level of interaction that you
need
to specify a location right and it's
sort of easy to use
so i say load and it opens up and
there's a little bin in here
actually the in the the current version
this is a sort of
the road version but in the version
that's in the hotel we've redone the bin
so that it's about this deep
so you can hold basically two feet by
one feet by one feet of stuff
and then there's a little tray that sits
inside so that when you put a toothbrush
or toothpaste or typical things
they sit up high so the person doesn't
have to reach down deep
so if you take the deep bin you put a
bag in typically and pull it out
so i load it up i'll put my i put my pen
in there
it's not like a magic trick it'll still
be there when it gets to the other side
um i say go and now it says i'm running
a delivery
makes a little cute noise and starts
going to its location if you're a
nine-year-old you can do this and sort
of keep
blocking it if i keep doing that it'll
try to find another way around sees that
it can't go there
and now it tries again and i messed it
up now this is kind of a small space
but it'll it'll re-plan and then say all
right now i can get through
um and this as i say works very well
reliably
in the in the hotel pretty simple um
idea it's um is it artificial
intelligence well it's
it's artificial intelligence from the
80s right we had planning algorithms and
search algorithms
um it's not conscious i'm pretty sure
hasn't been hit by lightning so
therefore and
i take my pen out it says please remove
your items i say all set
it asks how did i do if i give it five
stars i get a happy dance
it's always a nice little thing and then
it automatically
this it's actually delaying right now
the delay is artificial
because when our user initial user
testing we found people didn't like
the fact that it just left like you know
i want to interact with it i want to
take a selfie and so we
take it for another 10 seconds before it
leaves then it goes back to its dock
and and resets so that's that's sort of
what it does it's
yes incredibly simple right i can't
believe i'm at an electrical engineering
seminar talking about such a simple
thing
but it's also because it's so simple we
can work on the next hard thing which is
all the corner cases you have to deal
with in unstructured environments
right how do you get the algorithm so
that um
you know when it shows up at in the
elevator and
if there's people in the elevator or
there's a big cart in the elevator
that it does the right thing how do you
handle those cases i'll tell you this is
a true story i was watching
um the robot one evening and i was sort
of just
following it kind of as a safety driver
but not interacting right just it's
doing its thing
and um here's the here's the elevator
and the
robot comes around and in the back of
the elevator is this little girl with
her suitcase she just checked in and her
mother's there and she's standing there
with her mother and
the robot comes it's starting to come in
the door and the girl goes like a robot
and she runs up to it
and she's like this she's like petting
its face
right so the robot naturally is not
going to run her over
that's good but it's now she's standing
in the door of the elevator
and and the robot sitting outside and
she's blocked its path
so um she's playing with it doing
whatever she's doing and finally her
mother says
you know let the robot get in dear she
pulls her back by her shoulders
and the robot starts to get in and it
gets halfway through the elevator door
and the girl runs up to it again and
starts playing with it so now it's in
the elevator door
fortunately it's holding the door
remotely so it's not going to close on
her or the girl
on the robot or the girl and now
somebody from the bar who's been
drinking
comes around sees an elevator in the
door of the
i mean sits a robot in the door of the
elevator like oh this is holding up the
works
i can fix this you kicks it and he kicks
it again and he shoves it into the
elevator
and the robot unfortunately doesn't have
a temper or anything so it just
it like what i think you could put one
we could put one in yeah we
just talked about technology yeah we
have all kinds of robot self-defense
ideas um but in this case the the martin
luther king approach works you just
push it in and then the robot turns
around faces the door
releases the door rise up to his floor
and goes on does this delivery right
so it takes a lot of engineering to get
that kind of behavior
to work right and i can't promise it's
going to help with you know everything
that
anyone in a bachelor party happens to
think of but um
but i think we've done a pretty good job
of thinking through some of those cases
um so that's uh that's savvy one of the
remote operators
uh so so um in terms of like the phases
of the project in the first phase of the
project somebody from savvy oak always
follows the robot
um that was until thanksgiving then the
hotel was complaining because we
small company we can't follow 24 7. so
it's not available all the time so then
we came to an agreement
their staff will follow the robot and
we'll just monitor remotely and that's
the phase that we're in now and then the
next phase
will be one where the robot's going on
its own we're still monitoring it
remotely
and we'll always have the ability to um
help it out remotely if it gets into
trouble there are cases that are very
hard to deal with
or impossible to deal with so there's a
hallway and at the end of the hallway is
the room you're trying to deliver to and
in the middle of the hallway there's a
laundry or a housekeeping cart that's
parked
taking up too much space right you
simply can't get by a person could get
by a person could move the cart
the robot this robot isn't going to move
the cart right we're not even going to
try
and so we have to get help at that point
or at least we have to let the hotel
staff
know that this delivery we don't know
what it is it might be ice cream melting
right
this delivery has it's supposed to be
there within 15 minutes it's now been 10
minutes and
our path is blocked so those are the
kind of the kind of logic that
goes into taking care of those cases
and this is kind of another example of
kind of delight this is
i just was following the robot and i
caught this girl she saw the robot and
she just started
following it like all the way down at
some point she looks back at me and goes
like
why are you watching me you know like
well it's just so cute with that party
dress following the robot i
couldn't resist um the hotel spent a lot
of time
uh they moved it so when we first put it
in
we we're thinking this is all about
helping them
send deliveries more efficiently so
there's a front desk at the loft it's
round
um and there's like a an opening at the
back and so when you come in the front
door it's like over there and you come
to the front desk
we parked the robot back here along this
this wall
um you saw how i parked it over there
and it's kind of subtle and you don't
really notice it
well the same thing it's behind the desk
nobody noticed it and and the hotel
management started to get upset like
nobody's noticing the robot
so let's move it out so we changed the
docking post so that now the
front desk has to walk all the way
around like out by the front door
that's where they want to park it but
it's very visible to everybody in the
hotel
and they parked it right in front of a
um
they have this tower of lit up blocks
called let's say a loft all over them
and right in front of that they put this
sticker this uh butler parking sticker
and so the robot always parks on top of
that sticker now and then
it says snap a selfie and you take a
snip you snap a selfie with the robot
you get the aloft blocks in the
background very clever for them so
so anyway this is we i would say we
totally underestimated
the value of the delight part of the
robot right so we designed it for
utility for return on investment
and kind of keeping the cost down and
making sure everything was valuable
but starwood is you know we they did
this that video that i showed you and um
a whole marketing campaign around it and
had something like 1.3 billion media
impressions
in the first month so it's pretty it's
pretty good at capturing people's
imagination i think
what andy said earlier it's really about
some somehow robots just capture your
imagination and i'm a software guy you
know i came out of computer science here
but um what i found is whenever i'm
talking about robots people don't care
about the software they look at the
robot look
you know what it does is interesting
about what's underneath people don't
care as much about
so it's much easier to show oh i can
show you videos of all kinds of robots
using ross but showing you
video of ross would be really boring
except for the animations i guess
there's lots more robots and i won't um
i'm going to save some time for
questions so i won't go through all of
them
but um drones obviously huge right now
that's the amazon drone google has a
drone as well and there's you know 3d
robotics doing drones for agriculture
the google car we've already talked
about a little bit and
this uh security robot called nightscope
that
that's come out and and i've i mean i
could i could go on for
for a long time talking about lots of
different robots that are out there
but instead what i thought i would do is
take these as examples and go back to my
first list of how you distinguish robots
and see how they kind of fit so back to
the
10 ways to compare robots and let's just
go through them one at a time
so moving versus fixed most robots when
you think about industrial robots
they're fixed
but most of the robots that we talk
about and that are coming up now are
mobile
so that seems to be a characteristic
that's pretty important of a robot would
rule out
the microwave and the dishwasher and
things
the scratchbot and the industrial robot
arms obviously are fixed
and there's as you know a category of
industrial robot arms that are safe
enough not to have to go behind a cage
that are you know baxter and universal
robotics that are coming out
um and so i think you know that space is
moving in an interesting direction
light versus heavy um so i i moved
the pr2 down and the the heavier
delivery robots that can help you know
bring 500 pounds that's a big robot
this robot i left kind of at the top but
sort of this would be the most heavy
robot up there
at about 100 pounds so and probably not
necessary to be quite 100 pounds
although there's an interesting
trade-off about
the lighter you get the easier just to
steal so
um you know the 100 pounds you kind of
want two people to carry it you know
what
no measures yeah no yeah there are but
actually we do well we did it turns out
let acid batteries have the wrong
characteristics in terms of
number of recharge cycles so that's a
really important piece you want to put a
robot out in the field for years
and you don't want to have to be
replacing the battery every quarter so
we tried that acid
we contributed more than our share to
landfill and we stopped using them
so we've moved to a different chemistry
but it's not lithium ion for that reason
you pick a chemistry in the middle
that's more heavy because we don't need
the weight
we don't need the low weight we actually
want weight
in fact this battery i think has there's
a block of steel
about this big next to the battery just
to make up for the difference from lead
acid
um weak versus strong you might be
surprised when i put the pr2 on the top
but pr2 was designed to be
safe around people and so the amount of
payload that its arms can lift is
actually very small so in spite of the
fact that it weighs 500 pounds
it can't lift more than about 10 pounds
obviously drones you could imagine a
drone that could lift a lot but you
can't imagine it landing in your yard
safely and so most of the robots
here end up being weak i think as i'm
talking about service robots coming
forward it's sort of an interesting
characteristic
that uh weaker robots around people is
a sort of necessary thing so the
question is what can you do if you're
weak
to actually help people out or how can
you be strong and yet safe
indoor versus outdoors also an
interesting way to cut them i brought
back the
three outdoor robots most of the service
robots are designed for indoors and that
turns out to be a nice simplifying
assumption
it's not just so easy as making it
waterproof
or snow proof i mean imagine an outdoor
robot on the east coast right now
you might be struggling actually imagine
the google car on the east coast right
now
would not be driving but
the one thing is that the sensors that
are designed for video games that get
the high volume
are typically putting an infrared
pattern out eye safe
therefore not very powerful and when you
put them in the sun the pattern gets
totally washed out just think about the
white balance on your camera when you go
outside after it's been inside
and so there really is it's hard to
imagine
it's not impossible but it's hard to
imagine a robot that's
cost effective that goes both indoors
and outdoors you'd have to design for
that you wouldn't
come upon that accidentally
um scripted versus unscripted so um the
two in the corner
just are teleops so they don't really
count for either
um but this one's a little bit of a
a vague category so when i start talking
about the pepper and the now
and even the ethan tug those robots
you can you can program them they can do
some things autonomously
but they're typically scripted right so
the now is
you it's all about programming you pose
it into different poses then you have it
do a dance
on the unscripted side that's really the
ai planning
navigation right so you're you're
telling you're giving it a goal like
this
when we came in here at the beginning of
this just before the talk started
i just drove the robo down and built a
map right i never told it follow this
path to get there
i just said this is a location this is
location go there and then it it comes
on its own right so that's it's not
again not conscious but
um but not scripted either
um and then um flying versus grounded is
easy i i thought about filling the sky
here with lots of different drones but
you get the idea um and
and then talia versus autonomous so you
saw when henry used the pr2 henry evans
the quadriplegic used the pr2
he's using it in the teleop mode right
actually he's using what we called
um assisted teleop um or supervised
autonomy
he's he's he's doing something but
he's having the robot help him do it as
well right
and a good example of that when henry
wants to shave
the first version he had cartesian
controls so all right so you move the
razor up down left right
um and and you know he brings it over it
but
now you have to angle it there's six
degrees of freedom that you need right
and it's not easy to sort of
think in 3d when you're facing the other
way and get this thing done how long
it takes to get frustrated he's got
amazing patience
you think about living with what he's
living for 10 years he's got amazing
patients
but what we did was the georgia tech
students modeled
his head as an ovoid and then said okay
given that when when you click in the
picture let me calculate the normal to
that right this is something that's
really easy for robotics people
okay take the normal now i'm going to
just bring in the robot there i'm going
to stop one centimeter from the
from the surface and now henry can just
reach over and scratch and he gets it
exactly the right place right
so a little bit of programming
a little bit of intelligence human
intelligence
into build really clever models makes a
big difference in terms of how the
robots can be used
finally uncontrolled versus structured
environments i think that's
obviously for the service industry you
can do things there's there's
there have been robots for probably 20
years that are doing mail delivery in
offices
but they're following a trail i mean
literally a trail somebody they have
special
um ink that they'll put on carpet that
you it's invisible but the robot can see
it and it'll just follow that just like
follow just line following basically
the problem with that approach is of
course when somebody puts a box down in
the middle of the path
the robot just stops until somebody
moves the box
and and so it's nicer to sort of really
operate in that unstructured environment
and it's relatively straightforward to
model it that
the problem of how you i mentioned at
the beginning the problem of
navigating robots mobile robots
wasn't really solved in 1994 when i was
here
in 1999 using lidar's sebastian thrawn
who came here later and won the
darpa grand challenge for stanford when
he was at cmu that was his thesis
was basically solving navigation using
using lighter so
that's a problem that's been now solved
for academically solved for 15 years
right
and one of the questions we asked
ourselves the year 15 months ago was
if that's a solved problem how come
we're not seeing very many robots out in
the world using it
and so that's where we set out to do
and then finally this is probably the
most important one is demo versus
deployment so that
scenario i talked about the beginning of
you make a video and you compare my
video to your video
or i have a demo and you can see my demo
but there's a real big difference as you
know between
building something to demo once and
trying to put something out and leave it
in the field
and but i think a lot of people are
trying that right so i would put the
amazon drone in the demo category right
i think they're a long way from actually
delivering things with it
i moved um the scratch bot down a little
bit it's deployed
in one user it's not a business but it's
there's one of them
i um the
google car probably there's a lot more
google cars in the world than there are
pr2s but the difference is you could buy
a pr2 you can't buy a google car today
so i moved that one a little bit lower
and the same thing with the now you can
you've been
i think there's over a couple thousand
now's in the world now
um they've on their second generation
and then the ones in the bottom
are are available for sale um and
used more or less widely the um the
pepper robot they're making 10
000 of this year which is starting to be
a significant number and
apparently they've got orders for a
hundred thousand in the next
few years next three years so that's you
know i talked about the beginning
millions of robots right there's
10 12 or 14 million robots in the world
if you can make a hundred thousand you
can at least be one decimal point
right until you get to a hundred
thousand it's not that you haven't you
haven't really made a mark right
um that's where we're we're heading to
we hope so
um with that let me stop and just take
any questions you might have
yes why don't they have it come to the
desk and get the stuff then
why do they walk out to ah that's that
will
that's coming that's coming very soon
the reason the technical reason is that
in order to do that i have to integrate
with their desk systems or i have to put
a tablet on their desk
and then i have to secure it and i just
haven't um so we built this
we built this very simple stand-alone
system that just does its thing
um and now there's like one more piece
of it the thing that lets me call it
that we just have to put in
um but yeah conceptually that's on the
that's near on the agenda
yes um what's up acceptable in terms of
uh how long it will operate on a single
battery charge
um so it turns out it's not about how
long it'll
operate on a single battery charge it's
how fast you can recharge it
right that's what matters so this
battery technology we can recharge it
twice as fast as it discharges
batteries that's an old electric car
solution that nobody
ah so we asked this one and the reason
is
i asked this one and the reason is that
the battery needs to be low and in the
middle
and it's really inconvenient to get to
it no you push it through
you have an interpolating output
position that's what they need for the
cars yeah
that's a it looks interesting but it um
cars even can drive over it and do it
you don't have to stop
input out all right well maybe for the
next generation
but just out of curiosity so duration of
running versus duration of charging
so so it charges um twice as fast as it
runs which means that if i charge it 20
minutes out of every hour it'll run
all the time it'll run 24 7. right so
the what that means is at the aloft and
cupertino where it's deployed
the average delivery is about seven
minutes so that means i can do
five and a half deliveries an hour 24 7.
right
but it's but it can run for i think four
hours
um without any charge and so really what
happens if you got to the busy time
where you're
having 10 deliveries an hour which is
about
you can't do 10 you could do nine right
if you're getting
eight or nine deliveries an hour yeah
the battery will run down but hopefully
you don't get to do that
well actually i hope you do need to do
that sustained
if you go if you actually use this robot
enough that you need
that you that that's a problem then you
need another robot that's good for me
yes i'm still puzzled why did you put
the battery at the bottom of your
now you deliver and get batteries that's
the same process
no it's it's way lower right the tray
only goes put it on the bottom
sorry i've been there done that all
right
being frustrated i'm sorry it is i don't
think it's such a big deal
okay but um it's a conceptual deal i
will pass that on to the to the
mechanical engineering team as i said
yeah
they have the same story electrical yeah
have you thought about voice interaction
with the robot um
yeah we've thought about it we um
we haven't done that for a couple of
reasons one so
one thing is you could there's two parts
there are you can have the robot speak
right and as opposed to doing the little
beeps and whistles like r2d2 that it
does now
and you can try to do voice recognition
right so having the robot speak
without doing voice recognition sets
expectations up here
right and our philosophy is we keep the
expectations low and we try to
overachieve instead of
not achieving um in terms of speech
there uh the now actually the new
generation of the now
is doing word spotting to try to do this
but that's the
as well as they can do so they've got
voice speech recognition they're trying
to do word spotting using nuanced
technology
um the when you actually use this
you're in a noisy environment like the
lobby is not
an ideal place to be talking to it and
so we just
you know the complexity of trying to get
a microphone array so that you can do
speaker
um uh
speaker of location detection and then
focus there and and do all that stuff
it's that's a research project right we
didn't feel like that was something we
could deploy in a year
robustly and so it's not in the first
version yeah
yes
i was going to ask the same question
about the voice interface i was going to
ask about
uh first-time users even with a nice
clean interface
maybe a little bit not sure what's
happening here when something knocks at
the door
uh would there be an open microphone
speaker channel to the front desk so
that uh so we've talked about doing that
we did a lot of user testing early early
on once we had the robot
what we're happy to find out is that
nobody seems to have trouble using it
right this thing shows up it says here's
your delivery and the lid opens
for it you asked for it and the lid
opens and so
taking it out turns out to be pretty
easy and then we've got the fail safe so
sometimes people don't
complete the interaction they just close
the door um and so then the robot
waits a while then it times out and goes
back i first thought that that should be
like a 10-15 second timeout and we
didn't implement it we didn't hit it
like
either two minutes or we hadn't
implemented it yet
and the first time we saw this guy open
the door and we're like
kind of listening following the robot
but hiding around the corner so we don't
mess with the interaction we hear the
door open and then we hear the door
close like
what what happened you know and and now
like what's it going to do do we need to
go get it is it
stuck outside this door what's happening
i don't remember if the timeout was
implemented yet we had talked about it
um so we're like talking about what
should
what should we do and then 45 seconds
later the door opens again the guy comes
back with his cell phone he's taking
pictures
right so that's sort of the more typical
uh typical interaction so so we've left
it i think at about
one or two minute timeout now so just um
if you but it'll it'll yeah we haven't
had any problems with people
like not figuring out how to get their
stuff from it it's it's pretty obvious
yeah it's a typical thing to do without
that what i call a human human
computer interface yeah i mean early
monitoring phase and then
these are your improvements and so our
phases were
we follow it staff follows it with us
monitoring that allows us to
debug the monitoring tools and then um
then it'll go by itself with monitoring
and then eventually it'll be
more loosely monitored so it'll only
raise a flag when it notices there's a
problem
we have a pretty good task model at this
point of of the steps of the robot and
how long they take
so we can use that to say how long
you know how long before i raise a
yellow flag and then
somebody looks through the camera and
sees that you know there's some kids
trying to keep it from getting to the
elevator
then you decide what you're going to do
right taser or no i'm kidding
yes any thoughts on climbing stairs or
other obstacles
yeah it goes downstairs once
it's actually we've thought about it but
that that adds a lot of complexity to
the robot it turns out there is
actually a pretty robust way to get
upstairs and downstairs which is to use
a tread
um it's just really hard on the stairs
right
and so and it doesn't really work in
hotels because if you're going to do
that you also have to do fire doors
right hotels have this not all i mean
there's very few grand budapests right
so there's most of the hotels have uh
fire corridors around the staircases
so you go and they're always you know
concrete and ugly and stuff and they
don't want you to go
there and they all have fire doors so
that's it's only there for emergencies
so we got we actually when we did the
safety analysis we said well what
could go wrong with this robot and one
of the things was what if it falls down
the stairs because it's like 100 pounds
and it could hurt somebody
it turns out at almost all hotels and
all hotels that we'll go into
they have the fire doors and there's a
bar and we got lucky because the bar is
this high
right so we can't actually trigger it um
and i mean then that's like there's like
n failures before you get to that point
right it has to be confused about where
it is
if the bumper is a bumper on the front
that if it it's never supposed to hit
anything but if it does hit something
the motors lock out
so all these things have to fail for it
to fall down the stairs
she follows the crowd in an emergency
that gets out
yeah well i mean you can imagine that
that's one of those cases yeah
so we use a combination of at the core
the raw stuff is mostly in c and c plus
plus
um there's a good interfaces in ross for
python so you can you can script it and
we use that for a lot of the
a lot of tools and and like test tools
and that sort of thing
and then the user interface is all done
in javascript
so it's actually all a web app so i
could run that same what you're seeing
on the screen i could run on my laptop
and that's a really nice feature because
it allows us to um
you know build interfaces in the same
way that we can deploy and lots of
you know sort of classic web thing right
yeah were there any big surprises in
user testing
um i think that well one of the big
surprises was that
they wanted it to stay at the doorway
longer right we
we thought you know like again we had
this whole thing about efficiency like
let's get in get out
but that's not what they wanted they
guests seem to want to spend more time
with it
or and if they don't want to spend time
they can just close the door on it
um i think yeah that's probably the
biggest one i mean i told you the story
about the drunken
version of that yeah the stan
just stands there yeah well it's easy to
make a robot that doesn't work my friend
is coming to
the delivery for you yeah yes
what are your thoughts on detailed
robots in senior care homes particularly
with regards to the user interface
um so i think that the so we've done
in the in the next generation of the
hardware we've
slanted the uh tablet back a little bit
more
so that it's easier to reach over it um
if you're in a wheelchair
so i think this robot is close to
doing one thing in senior facilities and
elder care
it doesn't it it'll do the same thing
it'll do delivery right
it doesn't solve you know there's a
myriad of things that robots could help
with in eldercare there's people
you know working on research all over
the place it's not going to solve
loneliness you know a lot of classic
problems
but what it does do in in that direction
is it can take a load off of the staff
and let them spend more time with the
residents right and so that's the that's
the way that we think about
the value of this robot there take a
load off the staff
and then the other will fix that the
encounters may fix that but
but that's their option right um and and
we do the same thing actually in the
hotel when we talk about what value it
brings
a lot of the value is in letting you
re-work the process of the hotel
in order to do things more efficiently
and potentially to add services back
because one of the problems that hotels
have is
labor costs go up revenues don't go up
quite as fast
and so you get this you know squeeze and
when you get the squeeze the response is
we're going to cut services
and so there's a lot of services that
hotels used to routinely provide
i don't know if you've noticed but many
bars are going away right many bars so
you have food in the room
mini bars turn out to be a horribly
inefficient thing it's bad for you
because you've got to pay like 17
for peanuts and it's bad for the hotel
because those peanuts
they have to keep track of how long they
were in your room right and since
they're 17
they never get sold and so they have to
go around all the rooms and see like
what's the date on the peanuts
and that's incredibly labor intensive
and so they have to raise the price of
the peanuts
and sort of vicious cycle so they mostly
hotels are getting rid of that in
exchange for those little kitchens or
pantries down by the front desk so this
lets you kind of go back right you can
get back to the food and
snack in your room but without having to
tip all right it's one of the things
people love
it's another user testing thing people
go crazy about they don't have to tip
like really okay have they complained
that it's hard to dress up for holidays
um they always ask us to dress it up um
and you know the the bottler you saw the
the video the bottler they put this
everybody calls it a bow tie
they claim it's a collar but whatever
it you know it's uh they addressed it
the first version the picture they sent
was
amazing um in terms of like really
trying to dress it up
we we've basically gone to the point
where we've said okay
there's a certain so far that we'll go
we want to go and there's so far that we
really don't want to go so
you know on a regular basis you don't
want to have loose clothing and things
that are going to hang off and get
caught
so we don't want to dress it with
clothes you can dress it with vinyl
quite nicely using auto wrap technology
from 3m
you can um we're sort of saying you can
you what well we do
i don't know yet we should talk um
i uh so i mean the part of that's a is
sort of a business model question right
if i sell it to you and
you can go paint it if i put in a hotel
i don't want you just to go over and
start painting on it without the hotel's
approval and
um and our current business model is
that we're putting it available as a
service as opposed to selling it
but that's on the other side the skins
once you get into production with
plastics are not that expensive
so you could paint it and then i could
if i didn't like it i could take the
skins off and put new skins on
yeah what's your hope for list price for
this um
so we haven't announced yet but we're
we're trying to keep it in
a reasonable monthly fee that comes in
as a
you know very inexpensive basically is
our model i'm sorry i can't say more yet
never mind the price what's the cost
let me let me uh let me let me answer
that in this way
um it turns out it doesn't matter as
much as you would think
given this business model right given
our business model of renting it at a
monthly fee
the two factors in the cost are the cost
of the hardware
um and the cost of the service and
they're about equal
if you amortize out over three or five
years so
it's really you know we at this point we
might take a
trade-off and make a higher bomb cost in
order to get more reliability
just like if you were building you know
it's like you're building your own home
you're going to do it right
right if you're building a home that
you're planning to flip you might
cut some corners right we're not
planning to flip these so we're not
cutting corners
and because we everything is about how
we're going to make it so that we're not
going to have to service it as often
because that'll save us money in the
long term
so how do your customers look at the
value of this
is it replacement of you know room
service people
yeah how do they go about deciding yeah
i don't think it's it's not replacement
of room service
uh it could be um
the the staffing can change with any
technology the way that you staff
can change and so that's clearly one way
that they can look at the value
they can also look at as you know with
this robot you can now
offer not room service which implies
like a guy coming in your room and
setting a white tablecloth and
everything but you can imagine this
doing kind of a grab and go
different hotels have different policies
so some hotels you can order stuff from
outside
but they won't let the delivery people
go up to your room right well now they
can offer that service all the way to
your door
so that's you know that's a that's the
kind of service that can be offered so i
think
it's a combination of the marketing
value in the short term
the labor savings if that's appropriate
um if they if they re or the process
improvement if you look at it that way
and then the ability to add new services
which might actually increase revenue
yes kind of following on that question
then like
the delivery have there been any
requests or like how do you make it big
enough to hold a pizza then
exactly yeah that's one of the things
that's really hard and
yeah we haven't figured out how to make
it
it's a pain it's it's a small it's a
small pizza
and and that's actually one of it's a
good it's a good question the
the size of the robot and the scale of
the robot is driven
um in this generation by
we want to keep the footprint as small
as possible because when you go in the
elevator
every inch of additional diameter means
it's that much harder to be around
people and to squeeze through
we want to be able to go down the
hallway and you know when
like i can squeeze through this gap
without even turning right
the robot doesn't actually fit through
that gap and so and that's at this size
so so if i make it smaller i have even
smaller pizzas i can deliver
right if i try to hold up like this like
i could balance a pizza on here you
could imagine it wouldn't be hard to put
a pizza on top
but now how am i going to make it so
that i don't slap somebody with that
pizza when i'm driving around
we keep it all within a cylinder so that
we can reason more efficiently in 2d
yeah i was struck by the video of the
little girl in the
party dress um enjoying her
it was almost like alice with march hair
going through
um high technology is often a draw at
least in the early stages
walt disney put in monorails partly as
mass transit and partly because it added
ambience to its theme parks
chuck e cheese had robots as the main
thing
um i would think that just having this
thing wandering the halls
when they weren't needed or during the
off-peak hours having
extras of these absolutely just
wandering around would
get people's attention make them become
aware that they could buy things using
the service
and and buy income yeah that's right
actually one of the things that
plus security yeah yeah i mean
completely agree
and we talk about free interactions
so the interactions you can do when
you're not on a task
with people um and we've
been thinking about yeah what are the
other things you could do with it to
kind of
get it out there and and get it used um
because you do see a lot of people
like we've we've seen tens of people
who've
chosen to stay at the hotel just to see
the robot right so you it is a it is a
real phenomenon now it doesn't happen if
it's in every hotel
but in the near term that's that is a
draw
but you should tell all your hotel
friends that they should get one
where are you going to go next after
hotels
um so we haven't decided we're
looking at elder care at hospitals at
restaurants
at office buildings um i if it was
20 years ago like robots have been
coming for a long time if robots if it
had actually gotten here 20 years ago
i would have said office buildings right
but you know delivering
because printouts and stuff right but
paper is so 20th century it's like
you know even maybe the office is kind
of 20th century although there's still
an awful lot of offices out there
but what gets delivered in offices has
changed dramatically because of email
and because of
of computers in the internet sure you
donate one of the fourth floor for
friday lunches
database group well we have something we
have some to spare
yeah you already sort of alluded to this
how much did their food service did
their uh takeout or
room service ordering go up so that
people could
it's sitting out there as advertising
yeah people ordering
yeah so um so we don't i don't have good
data on
the the like how much additional revenue
that's true i might not be and that
would be a that would be a failing of
mine
because i was here in a computer science
instead of at the business school
yeah but it's a new line of business for
them to grab and go
yeah absolutely no it's definitely
something that's interesting i just
we've when we first started um
the hotels is conservative a little bit
about
wanting to adopt things one step at a
time and so they said
water bottles and toothbrush is fine
we're not sending up food
now they're saying okay you can do food
but packaged food
and i keep saying well you know i'd love
to send breakfast sandwiches up warm
ones
because we have an i7 inside it'll heat
it right
but they uh we haven't we haven't gotten
to that step yet but you know
it's been it's been just a few months
and we're kind of gradually going
forward
yes um have there been any talks about
changing
the architecture like for example if
you've got this thing doing the
grab-and-gos you don't need to dedicate
a chunk of the lobby to have the grab
and go
space you can just put it in a back room
or out of the way somewhere
i think i don't know if anyone's had
that conversation it's a little bit
early right
we kind of sprung this on the hotel
industry in the world in august
so i don't think they've thought about
re-architecting quite yet but
hopefully that would be nice the the
athon tug
they actually they've been around for
long enough that as people build new
hospitals they have been thinking about
how could you change the storage so
exactly what you're talking about and
they talk about that as one of the ways
that they can
make progress it's just that you don't
want to as a startup have a
business that's based on only going in
when a new building is built
unless you have a really good margin
yeah yes speaking of really good margins
uh 18 months out of the funding out of
the center and
stanford answer the stanford question
how did you do this startup
funding milestones
uh which bc firm yada yada so we um
we started so the team
the founding team came out of willow
garage willa garage shut down last year
in august
a year ago august
we a bunch of us decided that we wanted
to do a company that kind of
was doing something along the lines
robot for the service industry
i had announced in willow internally in
2011 that by the summer of 2014 we'd
have a robot in beta
um we almost got there we had the we had
the robot in beta we just
the company shut down nine months before
that um
but uh it was an elf i guess
um so a bunch of us
more people than actually founded the
company were considering joining us so
we all sat around
the zumi's dining room table for a month
in september
we tried coffee shops they're a little
bit noisy and we tried libraries and
they have all these quiet rules and
stuff so we just we started going in the
dining room
and just sitting around the table
everybody had their laptop and we were
brainstorming we knew a lot about
robotics we knew about what could be
done
we didn't know as much about what needed
to be done so we focused all on market
side and needs
and concluded that delivery was
something we wanted to do so once we had
that
stake in the ground i hired everybody
and the way
we got started we had a contract
that we were doing that was
profitable so we had some extra cash
from that and i put some of my own cash
in to get going
for the first few months and then um
then we went out and started raising
money once we had that prototype the one
that the flames
was behind the flames um that prototype
we could take in
hotels and we could have it drive around
the lobby it wasn't doing elevators yet
but that was enough to get the hotel
people interested then they were willing
to talk to
uh some of the uh the funders
and in the end it was the fact that we
went to the aloft and cupertino
we got lucky because that's the
technology adoption aloft
and and they're already a tech forward
brand so the first thing they did was
call starwood headquarters and
we were soon in touch with the global
brand manager who was then on
when we were raising money was on the
phone with people um
saying that he was interested i had
brand level and i had general manager
level
interest once you get that interest then
you can
hopefully get angel funding and we got
lucky jerry yang and ash patel came by
and liked what they saw and so they they
led the round
which would end up being about 10
funders kind of an angel round including
google ventures
but scott didn't give you money or larry
scott is not in this round well okay
larry is larry's not in the round but
google ventures was in the round so
okay yeah